Narcan est un médicament d'inversion de surdose si
nous ramenons quelqu'un de la
dette, donc c'est important parce que nous sommes
423 personnes mortes cette année seulement dans cette
ville
[Musique]
ici comme nous essayons de faire en sorte que tout le monde
le porte soixante-dix pour cent des surdoses
sont inversés par les personnes qui consomment de la
drogue avec quelqu'un d'autre comme 20 après
ce sont des gens avec des passants, donc ces
professionnels avec ça, ils sont le
plus petit morceau de tout ça
[Musique]
en ce moment
nous sommes sur le point de mettre nous allons  mettez trois
distributeurs automatiques
[Musique]
gratuitement
à la prime
la beauté primaire
euh c'est nasal dans la rue ce que nous
distribuons quand les gens demandent Narcan
nous vous demandons si vous l'avez utilisé récemment et tant
d'histoires sont là-bas euh
je  Je connais au moins une de mes
formations de bureau où la personne
a ramené quelqu'un de sa
salle de bain dans son immeuble de bureaux,
la plupart ne font que le diffuser dans
le monde et j'espère que cela prendra quand il
faudra
vous remercier à l'étranger
[Musique]